[Música]
y seguimos con nuestro espacio de
análisis en directo américa de francia
24 quiere saludar en este momento a más
romeros a la mar y también como se lo
dije a rosa y a daniela es para mí un
gusto y un placer trabajar con usted
todas estas mañanas unas mujeres
profesionales y también de buenos
sentimientos que hacen pues más
llevadero todo este duro trabajo de
informar sobre todo en tiempos de guerra
marc y sobre eso vamos a hablar porque
hoy 8 de marzo se cumplen 13 días de
guerra en ucrania cómo afecta este
conflicto a las mujeres pues buenos días
raúl y gracias por las palabras para
empezar sabemos que hay una ley marcial
no eso implica que los hombres deben
quedarse a luchar y que las mujeres
tienen que salir esto puede alimentar la
percepción de que el conflicto al final
afecta más a los hombres que a las
mujeres pero al final la guerra afecta a
toda la sociedad y afecta a las mujeres
de maneras que incluso un poco que den
hace que queden un poco invisibilizadas
por esa percepción importante destacar
que está viendo actualmente también un
grave problema con las mujeres trans que
todavía están identificadas como hombre
en sus documentos de identidad y que
deben estar sujetas a esa ley marcial
está viendo es uno de los problemas y
pues hoy 8 de marzo tenemos que recordar
que es para todas las mujeres hay dos
cosas básicas para decir uno es que un
conflicto y una guerra siempre supone un
retroceso de los derechos para todo el
mundo pero imaginemos en un conflicto en
osh cuando hablamos de derechos por
ejemplo de las mujeres que a veces ya
son difíciles de defender en un país en
paz eso es todavía más difícil en zonas
de conflicto segundo que la guerra
siempre refuerza el imaginario y el
discurso machista de que el hombre lucha
la mujer cuida y se refuerza ese
belicismo esa violencia que pues las
mujeres sabemos desde hace años que no
funciona para nada marc y la mayor parte
de refugiados que huyen son mujeres le
pregunto entonces los riesgos que esto
representa para ellas claro exactamente
no esa ley marcial una de las
consecuencias que tiene es que la mayor
parte de desplazadas de refugiadas sean
mujeres y eso conlleva que son
responsables de cuidar de abastecer a
las familias en unas situaciones
especialmente vulnerables difíciles y en
lugares extranjeros también es una mayor
exposición a situaciones de violencia
tanto violencia física como violencia
sexual pero particularmente también en
el caso de ucrania se enfrentan a un
riesgo de trata de personas las personas
ucranianas y especialmente las son las
principales víctimas de trata de
personas en europa antes de este
conflicto y entre 2017 y 2019 se
calculaba que hubo unas 49 mil víctimas
la inmensa mayoría mujeres y es un
riesgo que aumenta con este flujo
migratorio de hecho ya hay reportes de
personas que están yendo a las fronteras
a tratar de captar mujeres que están en
una situación tan vulnerable para
situaciones que van a convertirse
probablemente en trabajo forzado así que
tenemos que estar raúl también
pendientes de eso vale le pregunto
entonces otro tipo de violencia que
pueden enfrentar las mujeres ucranianas
en este contexto de guerra claro estas
son las que huyen también las que se
quedan en ucrania sabemos por años y
siglos de guerra que uno de los riesgos
a los que se enfrentan son la violencia
física no los cuerpos de las mujeres han
sido territorio de conquista en los
contextos de conflicto desde hace años y
tiempos inmemoriables el riesgo además
el problema es que viene de todos lados
por un lado del bando enemigo no con la
violación como uso como un tipo de arma
pero también de los propios soldados no
hace falta que vayamos muy lejos hay un
estudio por ejemplo de amnistía
internacional que recogió de estos 8
años de conflicto en la zona del donbass
y vieron que en la región de dones y
aumentó un 76% de las denuncias de
violencia machista en lugansk más del
150 por ciento otra conclusión además es
que las mujeres cuyas parejas estaban
combatiendo en el frente en el frente
tenían un riesgo mayor que las parejas
que sus que las mujeres que sus parejas
no eran combatientes de sufrir violencia
eso qué conclusión nos lleva pues que
las mujeres en estos contextos no están
a salvo ni fuera de su casa ni dentro de
sus casas tampoco a mediano y largo
plazo mar qué consecuencias hay para las
mujeres pues de estos retrocesos
inmediatos de derechos que vemos cuando
estalla la guerra se prolongan con el
tiempo por ejemplo en términos de acceso
a la justicia no los crímenes de
violencia sexual o de violencia machista
en los conflictos suelen quedar impunes
por una especie de encubrimiento
predominante en los cuerpos militares
por ejemplo también en términos
económicos sin duda es devastador para
todo el mundo pero reconstruir un
sustento de vida suele ser más difícil
para las mujeres también caen en picado
las tasas de escolarización entre las y
una solución a eso sería que las mujeres
también formarán parte de las soluciones
de los esfuerzos de las negociaciones de
paz de la implementación de la
reconstrucción de los países algo que no
siempre pasa por esta idea de que son
actores periféricos del conflicto marc y
por último hay que preguntar si algún
tipo de pronunciamiento no por parte del
movimiento feminista por supuesto toca
recordar las voces que llevan años
trabajando en este tipo y hay un un
pronunciamiento particularmente
interesante del movimiento feminista
ruso que emitieron una firme condena a
la guerra asegurando que es totalmente
incompatible con los valores feministas
y es lo que sucede al final es que desde
el feminismo se reivindica que la
igualdad no es que las mujeres también
puedan agarrar un fusil la idea es que
nadie tenga que agarrar nunca un fusil y
pues porque la histórica exclusión de
las mujeres ha hecho que busquemos
alternativas no sabemos por años de
violencia sobre nuestros cuerpos y sobre
nuestras vidas que esta lógica tan
militar de dominación de imponerse el
uno sobre el otro de subordinación de
jerarquías y de control no suele llevar
a ningún lado pues más gracias entonces
por toda esta información las mujeres en
el conflicto y también vamos a hablar de
ese tema con nuestra segunda mitad del
día